the american academy of pediatrics
which in its new guide on puberty
is discussing girls with erections
that's that's the phrase they've got a
new guide on puberty called u-ology a
puberty guide for everybody
targeted toward children ages 9 through
13 years old explaining how some girls
are actually boys and how girls can get
erections and that's totally normal and
totally fine
and these people have the audacity to
make fun of christians and jews and
muslims is superstitious
that what one thing that this conveys
just on a political point is that you
you really can't trust anything these
modern leftist medical associations have
to say they say you don't believe the
science you don't believe the cdc and
the who and the american pediatric
academy and you know well no if they
think that girls can get erections then
i don't trust anything they say because
they don't understand the most basic
elements of human nature so no i don't
trust them at all i trust a random blog
i read on the internet much more than i
trust these people because these people
are getting something fundamentally
wrong that i know for a fact is
is fundamentally wrong
this is
the kind of weirdness that is going to
enter into your political society if you
reject basic truth we're going way we
are going so far down this path
the the only way out i think is to try
to hold on to some grasp of the
tradition some grasp of reality someone
the other day pointed out that
conservatives they talk about free
speech and this then all they really
want is christian nationalism christian
nationalism is a contradiction i think
it's jen rubin at the washington post
christian nationalism is in many ways a
contradiction in terms because
christianity makes universal claims
lowercase c catholic claims about the
world and so it
christian nationalism is a con
conflicting sort of statement but
regardless okay let's use the phrase
christian what does that mean we
american conservatives want christian
standards and christian traditions in
society
and what's the alternative
pumping eight-year-old boys full of
puberty blockers
that's the alternative uh sign me up for
the christian nation please
hey where do i get me some of that
christian nation
which do you want if we look back at the
actual
practical application of these things
i think we're beginning to find out that
the people using their unfettered reason
people using they're just they're
inflicting their will on society to undo
everything we've come before that has
come before us
those people are giving us a society
that is unrecognizable and ugly and
something we don't desire and now when
we've got a little free speech we're
allowed to say it and we're allowed to
take our country back i'm glad you liked
that clip now
subscribe ring that bell get all the
notifications for the michael knowles
show you can go over to spotify apple
podcast wherever you get your podcast
type in the michael knowles show knowles
like beyonce k-n-w-l-e-s leave a
five-star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]